solve for s and we have s squared minus
2s minus 35 is equal to 0. so when you
have an equation like this what you want
to do you're going to find that with
traditional algebraic methods you're not
going to be able to actually solve for s
what you want to do is factor this
expression on the left hand side and
then use use the knowledge that if you
have the product of a bunch of things
equaling zero then at least one of them
has to be equal to a zero so let's
factor this thing on the left so s
squared minus 2s minus 35. so we want to
do is look for two numbers whose sum is
negative 2. so we want to look for a
plus b
whose sum is equal to negative 2 and
whose product is negative 35 so a
times b is equal to negative 35 and
since the product is negative we know
that they have to be of different signs
and so let's just factor 35 it could be
it could be plus or minus
1 and then
negative or positive 35 if i have na if
i have positive 1 and negative 35 they
add up to negative 34
if i switch their signs i get positive
34 that doesn't work then i go all the
way to 5 and 7 5 and 7. if i take and
i'll do it separately here if i take
positive 7 if i take positive 5 and
negative 7 what is the product equal so
that equals negative 35 as it should and
then if i take their sum
5 plus negative 7 that equals negative
2. so that worked so those are our two
numbers
and so you could use the pattern um
immediately to say okay this is going to
be s plus 5 times s times so you can
immediately go that hey this is going to
be the same thing as s plus 5
times s plus
negative 7. that that's that over here
is equal to zero but i'll do i'll add
one step in there just to show you that
we can use this information to factor by
grouping
so we can do here
is
we could say let's separate this
negative 2s as the sum here so let's
write it as s
plus 5 s
oh sorry s squared plus 5s
plus
negative 7s
minus 35 and of course we have that
being equal to zero all i did is i
separated this negative 2s into this 5s
and this negative 7s and added
parentheses
now you can factor an s out of here you
have s times
s plus five
and then two that you're going to add
you can factor out a negative seven here
negative seven times s plus five and
then we can factor out an s plus 5. so
you get s plus 5
right i'm factoring out an s plus 5. so
you get an s plus 5 times
what we have left is an s
plus negative 7 or that's the same thing
as an s
minus
s minus a seven and of course all of
that is equal to zero and i wanna make
it clear
a lot of times the way i learned it you
can actually skip pretty fast to that
step right over there because if you
have anything of the form if you have
anything of the form
s
s plus a times s plus b when you take
this product is going to be s times s
which is s squared plus s times b which
is bs plus a times s which is a s
plus a b
and so you can add these two middle
terms and you get s squared plus
a plus b s plus a b
so we found two numbers that add up to
negative two a plus b s and with their
product is negative 35 a b so we could
say hey if we know those two numbers if
a is equal to if a is equal to 5 and b
is equal to negative 7 then this just
becomes s plus 5 times s plus negative 7
or s minus 7. so that's kind of the
faster way to do it but it never hurts
to see that we can really just kind of
unpackage this negative 2s and do it by
grouping but now that we've factored we
can use the the realization or the
property i guess you could say if i take
the product of two numbers and s plus 5
is a number you are an expression you
could view it that way and s minus 7 is
another number let me write it here if i
had x times y and that is equal to 0 i
know that either x is 0 or y 0 because
their product is 0. so at least one of
them's got to be 0 maybe both of them so
we know over here either either s plus 5
is equal to 0
or
or
s minus 7 is equal to 0. now if s plus 5
is equal to 0 we can subtract five from
both sides and you get s is equal to
negative five
if s minus seven is equal to zero you
can add seven to both sides and you get
s
is equal to seven so those are both of
our solutions and we can even verify
that they work
so if you put negative 5 in here
negative 5 squared is 25
negative 5 times negative 2 is plus 10
and then you're subtracting 35
that does add up to zero so this one
works and then let's try it with seven
so seven squared is 49
minus 14
minus 35 well 49 minus 14 is 35 you
subtract another 35 you get a zero again
so they both work